Russia. The move coming as the Kremlin's war
against Ukraine near its second anniversary,
and as Ukraine loses ground on the battlefield.
Its forces recently withdrew
the eastern town of abdifka
after months of heavy fighting.
This unverified Russian footage
proports to show soldiers there
replacing the Ukrainian flag with their own.
Now, since February 2022,
the EU has banned goods worth over 43 billion euros
that would have been exported to Russia.
It includes advanced technology
items like radar systems,
drones, camouflage gear or weapons,
and luxury items sought by Russia's elite.
On the import side,
the goods under sanctions are even more valuable.
Russian commodities worth 91
more than 91 billion euros. Excuse me.
Are now banned across the block,
including coal,
iron, gold and steel,
as well as Russia's most iconic and coveted products,
vodka and caviar.
Here's a look at how Russia's economy is doing
under the penalties already in place.
The defense industry is currently
the most important pillar of the Russian economy.
Thanks to significantly increased government spending.
The defense industry accounts for 10% of GDP.
Other sectors,
such as the steel industry,
are also benefiting.
After the slump in 2022,
the Russian economy is now growing.
According to data from Moscow,
growth is also forecast for 2024.
What's happened is that's actually
more like the Soviet Union
and that it has high spending on the military
and in some cases heavy industry.
And at the same time
the level of consumption is falling for the population.
Um, they prefer Goblin.
But industrial
production is also doing surprisingly well.
For example,
in the automotive sector,
components are increasingly coming from China
after the Europeans withdrew from Russia.
Thanks to Chinese imports,
the Russian economy is being kept afloat.
China is of course
not officially participating in the sanctions,
so it is not a partner,
so to speak,
of western states when it comes to sanctions.
That's all good.
To finance imports,
Russia needs export income from gas sales.
These are fallen dramatically at times.
The EU's extensive
import band seems to have had an effect.
Tapping into new customers with new pipelines
is only a partial substitute.
The volume symbol